sexual assaults and rapes and things
like that in college campuses are
constantly making national news and so I
think having a method for self-defense
can only be a good thing
yeah I don't think that then RA knows
what it's talking about you have people
who are intoxicated you have people who
are trying to get others intoxicated so
that they can't fight back and just have
introducing weapons into that
environment is just elevating the risk
if they've been drinking or if they're
at a party where a lot of these may
begin where the offense may start I
don't think the firearm would would
really be that helpful in a lot of these
cases you're actually talking about
sexual assaults that are happening
between people who know each other
there's definitely the argument at many
of the sexual assaults are done by
friends or parties or things like that
but again that's one part of the
spectrum of protecting people it's about
arming people so they don't become
victims in the first place we should be
telling men don't rape instead of
telling other people don't get raped I
think that making us all responsible for
our own safety our own words our own
actions as soon as possible is a good
thing at least on this campus i know
that many students would feel very
uneasy a number of students don't like
even the police to have firearms on
campus